comenzamos nuestra sección dedicada a
las noticias económicas donde nos
acompaña nuestro periodista Jorge
Hurtado Jorge buenas noches cómo está
Buenas noches María clara muy bien y vos
Muy bien gracias empecemos con las
noticias de México porque la inflación
es la nueva actualidad Bueno ahí la los
precios se ubicaron en 7,91% tasa anual
al cierre de enero en contraste con el
7,86% en el que cerró en diciembre del
2022 el aumento de precios avanza por
dos meses consecutivos principalmente de
los alimentos según los datos del
Instituto Nacional de estadísticas y
geografía el aumento con respecto a
diciembre de 2022 fue de 0,68% lo que
sitúa la inflación en su nivel más alto
para un mes de enero desde el año 2001
pero el dato que más siguen los
analistas es la inflación subyacente una
medida que no tiene en cuenta a los
alimentos frescos el y ni la energía por
su volatilidad también aumentó 0,71% a
tasa mensual y se ubicó en 8,45% la tasa
anual los energéticos y tarifas
autorizadas no autorizadas por el
gobierno se elevaron un 0,37% en el mes
y un 2,52 anual el índice de precios de
la canasta de consumo mínimo conformada
por 176 productos y servicios escaló un
0,73% mensual bueno Y ante esta
inflación la más alta es más de 20 años
con esta respondiendo El Banco Central
Especialmente con los tipos de interés
bueno el banco sorprendió al mercado Y
subió 50 puntos bases las tasas de
interés que ahora quedan en el 11%, los
cinco gobernadores del Banco Central
votaron por este aumento de 50 puntos y
la decisión se anunció después de
conocerse el dato de inflación que
aumentó y se incidió por supuesto en
esta decisión del Banco Central el banco
de México se sorprendió a los mercados
también al desligarse y al superar el
ritmo alcista de la reserva Federal
estadounidense con un incremento que fue
el doble
que la que anunció la semana pasada en
Estados Unidos Aunque hay que tomar en
cuenta que en Estados Unidos encadena Ya
seis meses consecutivos a la baja en su
tasa de inflación la decisión política
monetaria sorprendió a los analistas
mexicanos Pues el consenso esperaba Un
aumento solo de 25 puntos ahora los
analistas esperan que el banco vuelva a
subir su tasa de interés y que cierre
este año en un nivel del
11,5%. Bueno y con estos datos entonces
Jorge Cuál es el panorama para América
Latina especialmente porque la
calificadora moody's acaba de hablar
tanto sobre el crecimiento que va a ser
menor como los costos de financiamiento
que se esperan sean mayores bueno en
resumen dice que son negativas el
vicepresidente y oficial senior de
crédito de este grupo de riesgo soberano
de la calificadora Jaime rushe mencionó
que los más altos costos para tomar
deuda menos espacio fiscal y débiles
perspectivas de inversión así como
tensiones sociales persistentes y un
lento crecimiento económico marcan a la
región de latinoamérica aunque también
destacó como positivo una limitada
exposición a las tensiones geopolíticas
globales y una dinámica de deuda
relativamente estable para América
Latina si bien múlties prevé un
incremento en 2023 en la tasa de
incumplimiento de pago de deuda No
espera que alcance el pico que alcanzó
durante la pandemia del cobi 19 y
mientras tanto El Salvador sigue
recibiendo millones con las
criptomonedas tan solo en 2022 recibió
más de 126 millones Bueno aunque es
importante señalar que eso es apenas el
1,63% del total de las remesas que
recibe según el Banco Central de ese
país los datos muestran como la
aceptación del bitcoin que fue adoptado
como moneda en curso legal en septiembre
del 2021 ha sido ha ido a la baja desde
entonces mientras que los expertos
señalan su limitado impacto en la
economía salvadoreña solo entre enero y
diciembre del 2022 ingresaron a El
Salvador
7.741 millones de dólares en remesas
familiares de las cuales sólo 126
millones se dieron mediante las
billeteras con criptomonedas solo en el
2022 el bitcoin perdió casi el 60% de su
valor de Mercado una encuesta de la
universidad centroamericana reveló que
74 décadas y en 100 ciudadanos
salvadoreños manifestó no haber
utilizado el bitcoin durante ese año el
21% dijo que lo usó una vez y el 5% dijo
que nunca lo usó pese a esto la
criptomoneda es la mayor apuesta
económica del gobierno del presidente
nayib bukele bueno y cambiamos
totalmente de tema y nos vamos a
Sudáfrica que ha sido un país
históricamente afectado por la falta de
agua y ahora son los cortes de
Electricidad los que los tienen al borde
ya el estado declaró estado de
catástrofe bueno allí los cortes de
Electricidad son de hasta 8 horas al día
y afectan a hogares fábricas y empresas
según el presidente sudafricano civil
rama fosa la declaración permitiría su
gobierno eximir de cortes de
electricidad a los servicios esenciales
como en los hospitales y también en las
plantas de tratamiento de agua y
permitiría su gobierno comprar energía a
los vecinos de forma de emergencia años
de corrupción y falta de mantenimiento
hacen que scom que es la compañía
eléctrica de ese país sea incapaz de
producir suficiente energía pero la
energía no es el único mal Sudáfrica
tiene las tasas de desempleo más
elevadas del mundo un
32,9%, una tasa de crecimiento del
producto interno bruto prevista para
este año casi nula en el 0,3% y la
familia por supuesto agobiadas por la
subida de los precios de las materias
primas que están ya causando protestas
sociales una difícil situación Jorge
Gracias por las noticias económicas
gracias a vos y nosotros continuamos con
el debate aquí en 24
[Música]